what do you think about something you've
written about uh what do you think about
the mass surveillance programs by the
NSA and also probably by other
organizations CIA FBI and others
um and broadly what do you think about
the importance of privacy for the
American citizen okay I believe that the
FBI
should be abolished
because I believe that its culture was
so corrupted by its first director
John Edgar Hoover J Edgar Hoover
that it is impossible to reform the FBI
to make its uh agents honest
to force them to obey the Constitution
the the first fourth and fifth
amendments especially
um
and it's a culture that cannot be
changed
Hoover established the culture and no
FBI director since has been able to
change it
if you go online
I did on YouTube a video
for the ACLU of Massachusetts it was
when I was on the board it was probably
when I was president of the board I was
president of the board for two years I
was on the board for 20 years
and I did a a video about advising
people to never ever ever talk to an FBI
agent when they come knocking on your
door
can you uh um briefly explain the
intuition yes why not to talk to an FBI
they have a system
when they come in and interview you
two agents show up never one
asked the question the other one takes
notes the the note-taking agent takes
those and it goes back to the office and
types up a report called the form 302
which is the official record of what was
asked and answered
so when I have a client interviewed by
the FBI
I show up
and
and I always agree or almost always
agreed the interview
but I bring a tape recorder
and I say all right I'm going to take
this and they say well we're by
regulation we're not allowed to do the
interview of the state
the the record is the 302 the agent is
taking notes I say well I have a policy
too my policy is to never allow a client
to be interviewed unless it's recorded
so that's unfortunate but we're gonna
have to end this meeting and the Agents
get up and leave
and the I have never seen a form 302
that I considered to be accurate the
agents were write down what they wish
you had said yeah rather than what you
said it is a wholly corrupt organization
that has not gotten any better since
Hoover dive and fundamentally the the
corruption is in the culture that is uh
resisting the the the Constitution of
the United States correct the first and
fourth and fifth correct it's not it's
not Financial corruption it is um it is
corruption of the mission
and um I think it should be abolished
and if we need a federal investigative
agency
should be a new name a new culture
wholly new members a new director and um
the it's it's impossible to uh to reform
the FBI can you elaborate on what
exactly is broken about the FBI is it
the the uh the famous saying uh from uh
Stalin's KGB head uh Barry uh show me
the man and I'll show you the crime
right is it that kind of process it's
that kind of process they decide who's
guilty and then they go about concocting
a case against the person who's who who
they want to get so the goal is not to
find the truth or
uh to solve the solve the case and close
it and in Kansas City reputations
but to show that an innocent man is
guilty is also solving the case from
their perspective
so to falsely
convict or uh falsely imprisoned an
innocent man is also solving the case
well it closes the case if they fall
asleep in prison innocent man
their issues in closing cases
so that's the FBI but uh broadly
speaking about the surveillance aspect
of this what are your views uh on the
the the right that an American citizen
has to privacy well
um wiretapping and electronic
surveillance are very very intrusive
and um I think that the
circumstance
that these tools are used should be
narrowed
for example they're used in a lot of
drug cases
since I don't think drugs should be
illegal in any event I certainly think
that it's a terrible violation of
privacy
to to use wiretapping in a drug case
I could see it in cases of murder
um possibly in cases of serious
extortion
but on other kinds of kinds of crimes
whether they wiretap especially drug
cases I believe drugs should all be
legalized anyway
um I think it's um the the the the the
price we pay as Society is not worth it
there's uh on the Wikipedia page for
nothing to hide you're cited in fact
your book that you gave me today three
felonies a day is cited so nothing to
hide argument that's an argument that uh
if you're a well-behaved citizen
that you have nothing to hide in there
for your privacy can be violated well
the problem is that under the federal
criminal code
particularly the federal criminal code
um
it is very easy to be charged with a
crime now why
under the Constitution
the federal government does not have
plenary criminal jurisdiction that's up
to the state
how is it the thief feds indict in so
many areas of American Life
it's because the Supreme Court has
allowed the following absolutely insane
situation to prevail
anything can be made a federal crime
if in the course of the commission of
the crime
the means of Interstate communication or
travel or used
that means that if you commit a crime
which is ordinarily would be a state
crime and you use the telephone
or you send a letter
it suddenly becomes Federal
that means that the limitation that the
founding fathers who wrote the
Constitution
intended
to keep the feds out of
daily life
and to give that jurisdiction to the
state
has been completely thwarted
because I can't think of the a case
where somebody doesn't use a telephone
in the course of
planning discussing something that's
arguably Criminal
and so this limited Authority the
federal government
to bring
charges in criminal cases is illusory
feds can indict a ham sandwich
so basically everybody is guilty and if
uh if if the if the feds want to bring
you in they can find a way and that
allows them
to terrorize people who are dissidents